Guten Morgen Thomas.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Aber wenn dem nobel das mit dem Dynamit so peinlich war dass er dann Nobelpreis gegründet hat steht uns dann bald auch in Zuckerberg Preis bevor.
Ja aber erst nach dem amerikanischer Präsident war oder.
Aux
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer a270 vom 5. Oktober 2018.
Life in eurer Kopfhörer hinein geströmt nicht stimmt gar nichts gar nicht live alles aus der Retorte aber wir sprechen das jetzt hier live ein wir ist meine Wenigkeit der tippen und natürlich Thomas der.
Heute mal wieder ein springt weil die muss immer noch der Suche ist.
Es offline Erstauflage habe ich.
Ja bisschen bisschen offline ab und zu meldet das nicht NIKEiD ja also machen wir das dann heute mal wieder ne.
Das gibt leider.
Wir haben noch keinen Nobelpreis bekommen ne.
Nein aber Nobelpreis für Informatik dass wir doch eigentlich mal was oder.
Das ist jetzt ist die Frage was da genau für Durchbrüche gefeiert werden sollen.
Ja vielleicht steigert sich dann ja auch irgendwie die Kreativität und die Qualität in diesem Fach das könnte ganz hilfreich sein.
Ja na ja ist ja nicht so dass jetzt ich Durchbruchs frei wäre dieses Segment und
interessant habe ich heute ehrlich gesagt so noch nie drüber nachgedacht aber das ist tatsächlich etwas was nicht so richtig getrackt wird so die ganzen Durchbrüche finden irgendwie statt weiß vielleicht da noch sehr viel schwerer ist als in der klassischen Wissenschaft,
Erfindung auf bestimmte Leute zurückzuführen weil wir jetzt einfach noch.
Sehr viel mehr in dieses alles ist irgendwie offensichtlich und irgendwann kommt man drauf.
Pinkafeld na ich meine was was will was wissen sagen wer jetzt irgendwie künstliche Intelligenz.
Erfunden hat oder so ja also sicherlich gibt's da die ganze Menge Leute die in dem Bereich Durchbrüche zu Durchbrüchen beigetragen haben aber das jetzt eben auch so ein heureka Moment runterzubrechen dürfte.
Yaparim der Nobelpreis für dir auch nicht für konkrete Produkte vergeben sondern eher für Grundlagenforschung also es gäbe keinen Informatik Nobelpreis für ein iPhone aber vielleicht war sowas wie Bitcoin ja
Ja und deswegen ist schon die Frage so
wie wie weit lässt sich das dann in den einzelnen Menschen oder Teams vom Vorstand fassen aber wenn es ein anderes wäre wäre es gut ob es praktisch tauglich ist muss man sich die Helene Ruppel.
Das könnte auch schwierig ist unser Toshi nakamoto auf die Bühne zu bekommen.
Der Weg zu finden wir Ihnen finally mein Geld habe ja das ist so vielleicht das einzige womit man in der Auslegung.
Genauso das ist das ist der Moderne Investigativjournalismus Nobelpreis für Bitcoin.
Na gut aber solang für Datenschutz Privatsphäre und so weiter auch noch keine Nobelpreise Gericht gibt's bis war mal gucken,
mach mir doch gleich mal vorne an deinem Unternehmen was ich nicht unbedingt für den Privatsphäre Nobelpreis bewirbt.
Ja aber vielleicht irgendwann mal Stifte Dich gab Mark Zuckerberg muss das alles irgendwann mal peinlich sein
also erinnern uns alle noch Anfang diesen Jahres gab es den Skandal rund um Cambridge analytica die von Facebook so ungefähr 87 Millionen Nutzerdaten abgezogen haben.
Und in ähnlichen Dimensionen befindet sich der aktuelle Skandal ca 50 Millionen
Nutzerdaten sollen über eine Sicherheitslücke von Facebook geklaut worden sein
das ganze ist inzwischen nicht offengelegt worden angeblich gab es eine Lücke von über die profilvorschau und zwar ein ganz lustiges Video nämlich das.
Zur Klärung also wenn wir sagen 50 Millionen Nutzerdaten meinen wir die Daten von 50 Millionen Nutzern.
Dart mit Daten ist es halt so ein bisschen wie.
Was hat das kann man wie nicht so richtig bezifferter wie viel das ist also wie viele Daten das jetzt sind in der Menge lässt sich schwer ausdrücken das kann man dann auch interpretieren wie man möchte aber 50 Millionen Leute sind angibt.
Genau und 50 Millionen Menschen sind betroffen bei 90 Millionen Menschen wurde dann gleich eine Maßnahme ergriffen nämlich die wurden aus ihrem Facebook-Profil ausgeloggt und mussten sich dann wieder neu einloggen.
An das Passwort dieser Betroffenen NutzerInnen sein gebe ich nicht kompromittiert worden sondern Access Token seid so Didi.
Technischer Variante Zugriff auf dieses Profil zu erlangen Diva kompromittiert
und wahrscheinlich sind davon die Daten betroffen die auf dem eigenen Profil auch einsehbar sind es spricht alle möglichen biographischen Daten die da drauf stehen womöglich das gesamte soziale Netzwerke so die Freundesliste ab und natürlich auch alle Posts die man vielleicht auf nicht-öffentlich gescheit.
Matura nur einem gewissen Personenkreis eingeschränkt hat also
werden im Grunde eine peinliche Lücke die hier aber definitiv wieder mal zeigt das face
einfach überhaupt keine Qualität bei seinem Produkt hat und und dieser enormen Verantwortung von soviel Datenbeständen überhaupt nicht gerecht.
Wenn man davon betroffen ist und falls man irgendwie so in der letzten Woche oder ist rund um die Zeit wo diese Sendung am 5. Oktober aufgenommen wird befragt wurde sich noch mal einzuloggen auf Facebook das ganze könnte sich auch niederschlagen auf.
Drehzeiten wie Spotify Instagram oder Kinder wo man sich ja auch über Facebook einloggen kann.
Du bist dann ja sozusagen der Master Schlüssel zu allem möglichen Diensten und auch hier könnte natürlich dann Daten abgesaugt werden bei man auch mit diesem ep.iii Keys auf diese Art tritt Dienste Zugriff gehabt,
Kante
und was ist jetzt irgendwie schon mal ganz spannend ist ist das Facebook hier auch irgendwie K sagt ja ist uns passiert und die Krisen-PR scheint schon irgendwie einzutreten dass sie genau sagen das ganze ist seit Juli 2017 ein Fehler bei uns gewesen wurde massenhaft ausgenutzt und jetzt haben wir es ab
tellason.
Wurde massenhaft ausgenutzt haben auch Erkenntnisse darüber wie viel.
Genau daher kommen die 50 Millionen Betroffenen.
Ja gut also ausnutzen im Sinne von die Daten wurden überhaupt erstmal irgendwie zugegriffen ob sie ausgenutzt im Sinne von weiter getragen wurden oder so ist damit die es noch nicht.
Ja oder hast Datenschutz.
Navas.
Was datenschutzsicht wenn wenn der Verarbeiter deiner Daten irgendwie dient die Abhandenkommen dann ist deine Privatsphäre schon betroffen.
Dann dann hast du auch sogar schon Schadensersatzansprüche es gibt jetzt auch schon solche Forderungen also da kursiert gerade die Zahl dass das Facebook 1,4 Milliarden Euro nach datenschutzgrundverordnung kosten kann.
Zeige die Kommissarin wäre Jura war hat da schon mit einigen Tweets zumindest mal gesagt dass das so definitiv was ist wo die EU tätig wird und.
Was doch ein bisschen verbunden aber eigentlich freut ist dass die irische Datenschutzbehörde sich da jetzt auch eingeschalten hatte.
Warum willst du das jetzt so besonders.
Ja bei Tieren im Grunde.
Dafür bekannt sind eigentlich überhaupt keine Gesetze ernstzunehmen bei den Konzernen die sich bei ihnen ansiedeln egal ob das jetzt Steuergesetzgebung Datenschutz oder irgendwas ist.
A und und die haben die weltweit besten Leute die perfekte schuld daran sind überhaupt nichts zu tun das
insofern dass die proaktiv tätig werden finde ich schon irgendwie lustig sie sind zuständig also sie sind mit facebook dass er seinen Sitz in Irland hat auch auch die die am nächsten dran sind.
Man kann sich trotzdem beschweren gehen jetzt sind diesen Fall wenn man jetzt z.b. bei Facebook gefragt würde sein Passwort neu einzugeben.
Kann man davon ausgehen wenn es betroffen kann man schon irgendwie zu lokalen Datenschutzbehörde gehen und sagen räusper ich will hier mal dass ihr euch das näher anschaut.
Tandogan Unterschied machen weil die sich auch irgendwie leichter tun wenn sie wirklich
Grete complains von Nutzern haben und man muss sich hier auch nicht auf die Sicht der Dinge von Facebook verlassen also die Datenschutzbehörden haben auch das Recht da wirklich mal selber Fakten
herauszufinden Stimmen dieser Zahlen stimmt die Zeitleiste ist die Person jetzt hier konkret betroffen die können wir doch noch will.
Mit der Macht die sie aufgrund der dsgvo haben sich den Fall genauer anschauen und das sollten Sie glaube ich auch.
Also könnte teuer werden müssen aber noch.
Ja ja also im Grunde ist es auch wieder so eine Sache für für Max Schrems weil er ja genau derjenige ist der Datenschutz jetzt teurer macht für die Unternehmen
und genau da glaube ich wäre auch ein gefundenes Fressen weil ich meine das ist klar nein.
Ein Mäppchen und
was vielleicht den alten auch nicht so bewusst ist Datenschutz macht natürlich müssten wenn du auch Datensicherheit hast also wenn deine IP einmal mit zehn Löchern ist und alles ständig raus fließt dann ist wurscht was in deiner Datenschutz policy,
und dadurch würde ich jetzt hier auch eben bei Facebook seiner Pflicht nicht nachgekommen ist, mit dem mit unter dsgvo kauh gegen so eine
eigentlicher Sicherheitslücke tätig.
Ja ich bin an der Stelle muss man natürlich auch wieder sagen inwiefern ist.
Shit happens Fehler passieren ja das muss man ja auch akzeptieren also diese dieser Ruf nach einem fehlerfreien System.
Den kann man natürlich gerne aufstellen aber da muss man dann immer wieder mit diesem klassischen Politiker Spruch Antworten weißt schon hundertprozentige Sicherheit werden wir niemals haben und.
Ich denk mir mal so wenn man jetzt irgendwie einen Dienst anbietet da kann man ja auch nach besten Gewissen.
Agieren nach besten können man kann die besten Leute haben es werden halt Fehler probier passieren.
Und am Ende ist es ja dann für die meisten Leute auch wirklich entscheiden.
Wie wird nach dem Entdecken eines solchen Fehlers damit umgegangen es hat sich die Frage kann man einem Unternehmen.
Oder kann ich mal nur warum Unternehmen WGZ Primera jetzt erstmal um Unternehmen vorwerfen Fehler zu machen.
Ja also ist sozusagen allein das Entstehen von Fehlern
bei der täglichen Arbeit die dann zwar eine negative Auswirkungen haben an sich
schon eine verwerfliche Nummer und ich rede jetzt nicht über aktuelle Gesetzeslage soll jetzt mal nur das Ganze aus einer philosophischen Betrachtung heraus ne weil man kann Fehler ja nicht.
Verhindern also wenn das möglich wäre dann dann dann gebe es perfekte systemboxen glaube da sind wir uns einig die wird es nie geben.
Kann ich ich.
Also Wasser sozialen der Grad an Verwerflichkeit der hier gemessen werden muss um solche Ansprüche daneben auch gesetzlich zu legitimieren.
Also die die die Sicht der datenschutzgrundverordnung versucht das Ganze so zu
so eine Klammer zu setzen dass du sagst die ja.
Der potentielle Schaden für die Betroffenen ist das was die Verhältnismäßigkeit ausmacht also wenn du kleine startup,
du bist und als Unternehmen noch recht jung und du hast irgendwie ein paar tausend Nutzer ja theoretisch du kannst da auch eine Strafe kassieren aber es liegt immer immer messenger Datenschutzbehörde wie hoch die ist dieser rund 4 %
gebala Konzernumsatz Strafen sind ja nur bis zu.
Das kann auch niedriger sein und hier ist es aber so das ist ein Unternehmen ist was
ja Milliarden Nutzer hat und deine deinen Umsatz wo auch diese 1,4 Milliarden Euro Strafe ja irgendwie Peanuts sind
das tut schon weh aber das ist ein Kratzer und noch nicht irgendwie so ein Schuss ins Knie.
Und insofern finde ich diese Herangehensweise dass du sagst ihr hier mehr.
Nutzerin Daten du hast umso höher ist deine Verantwortung und deine Sorgfaltspflicht
und wenn diese Daten besonders sensibel sind wie geschlechtliche Identität oder sexuelle Orientierung Gewerkschaftszugehörigkeit und so dann hast du noch mal mehr Sorgfaltspflicht
das ist finde ich schon der richtige die richtige Herangehensweise im Grunde wäre es ja auch hier so dass man sagen könnte
Cambridge analytica war irgendwie noch bevor die datenschutzgrundverordnung in Kraft.
Das war eben wieso April herum und das wäre sozusagen der erste Fall der wirklich unter den neuen EU-Rechts Rahmen fällt und
du kannst ja auch Warnschüsse absetzen theoretisch ja aber ich finde bei Facebook braucht man keine Warnschüsse mehr weil
die sind stark genug in der Kritik und.
Da da hat's wahrscheinlich auch etwas mit fehlenden internen Qualitätsmanagement zu tun und einer gewissen move fast and break things mäßigen Risikobereitschaft das ist ein Zitat zum tackeberg
insofern ich glaube schon das ist ja irgendwann auch mal im Preis der gibt braucht weil.
Ansonsten kann man als Unternehmen dass das Datenschutz komplett egal es hat einfach wirklich wunderbar Gewinne machen also das schönste Beispiele für für mich ist immer Ashley Madison ich habe diesen Fall noch keins das war diese.
Diese Datingbörse ne.
Genau mit dem wunderbaren Slogan life is short have an affair
Anthering ist auch irgendwie mal glaube ich gesamten unserer Datenbank weggekommen und hat sich herausgestellt dass die die Typen die dort sich angemeldet haben hauptsächlich mit Bots gechattet haben die ganze Zeit
aber trotzdem das war halt irgendwie verheiratete Menschen Priester Leute beim Militär und
ja also die dir gern dein Leben wurde zerstört da gab es danach mindestens zwei Fälle von Selbstmord zu mir bekannt.
Von von Seiten die halt wirklich auf seinem Abschiedsbrief gesagt haben.
Kann so nicht wenn mein Bild komplett zerstört ist von mir selber und das andere von mir haben dann kann ich einfach nicht weiterleben.
Und obwohl das so gravierende Einschnitte produziert hat diese dieser Datenleck dem Unternehmen geht's wahnsinnig gut also Ashley Madison hat sich wunderbar erholt davon und die PR hat Ihnen auch nicht geschadet und inzwischen machen die wieder fette Gewinne.
Wart ja mal gucken ob jetzt die EU-Kommission bereitet Facebook sturmreif schießen ich schätze mal es wird wohl irgendwo dazwischen.
Kommen wir nach Österreich.
Gute Nachricht.
Unwissentlich müssen ein Jingle dafür haben.
Oh ja oh ja einen guten Nachrichten Jingle.
Stimme eine gute Nachrichten sengel Vorschläge werden gerne entgegengenommen.
Was sind passiert was ist denn los ich dachte Österreich ist dem Verderben na und alles wird jetzt schlimmer.
Aber es ist auch nur ein kleines Zwischenhoch oder was passiert.
Es ist ganz lustig also wir
man muss ja alten in unserer des britischen arbeit ist ja ganz viel Klein-Klein mit der Lupe durchgesetzte drüberschauen und genau beobachten was denn der Gesetzgeber so tut und
ja ich fange wahrscheinlich von vorne an also
die die die österreichische schwarz-blaue Bundesregierung hat dieses Jahr lange überfälliges neues Telekommunikationsgesetz,
vorgestellt und in dem Gesetz sind einige gute Sachen drinnen wie z.b. höhere Strafen für ne Totalität Verletzungen
bis zu 10% des Konzern Umsatzes was super gut ist das ist so absoluter Spitzenreiter nur Großbritannien hat eine ähnlich hohe maximal Strafe für nett veraltet Verletzungen.
Und davor war die irgendwie so bei 57000 Euro bis gar nichts und insofern haben wir doch super gejubelt.
Uns dass dieses Gesetz ging daneben im Begutachtung viele viele Dickhäuter haben Meinung dazu abgegeben.
Und dann normalerweise ist es so irgendwie ein Ministerium dein Gesetz in Begutachtung.
Welches Gesetz war denn das jetzt eigentlich.
Das Ticker geht das Telekommunikationsgesetz und dann ist es so nachdem du Begutachtung hast nimmst du dir das ganze Feedback schaffst du das an und dann gibt es einen,
Regierungs
Bundesregierung verabschiedet also da sitzen alle besseren zusammen und dann hast du diesen gesamten Beschluss der geht dann ins Parlament.
Arm und normalerweise ist es so wenn du irgendwie Dinge ändern willst.
Dann schreibst du die schon bei der Begutachtung rein damit die Leute dazu Stellung beziehen können das ist eigentlich der Zeitpunkt wo die Öffentlichkeit auch irgendwie informiert wird das neue Gesetze hier beteilige dich doch
und in diesem Fall war es jetzt so das Begutachtung ist abgelaufen einige Wochen vergehen,
dann kommt die Regierungsvorlage an da sind einige Änderungen drin
da ist nämlich eine ganz lustige habe ich auch noch nie gesehen an ihren juristischer Taschenspielertrick non den der der Termin Uni untergekommen ist.
Also was hier passiert ist ist das dynamische IP-Adressen zu Stammdaten erklärt werden dynamische IP Adressen sind.
Die Adressen die wir auf unserem Heim Internet von unserem
Provider zugewiesen bekommen die uns zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt auch eindeutig identifizieren im Internet und über die man auch und eine sowas wie eine Lenkererhebung machen kann also wer war zu diesem Zeit.
Mit dieser App ihr unterwegs okay.
Dann kriegt er es irgendwie den Anwaltsbrief oder die Vorladung vor Gericht also iP-Adressen sind wichtig für Strafverfolgung um rauszufinden wer es hinter dem Internet-Anschluss und in Österreich ist es so dass zu den Stammdaten gehe in 10 nur die klassischen statischen IP-Adressen
also die die du wirklich im Vertrag dazu kriegst ich hätte gerne noch eine IP before Adresse damit ich bei mir zu Hause den Heimserver betreiben kann
aber die dynamisch IP-Adresse dies oft auch über Monate hinweg dieselbe aber sie zählt nicht der Standard
sondern sie es eigentlich schon etwas das aus dem Kommunikationsvorgang entsteht und insofern auch und das sagt doch die Rechtsprechung unter das Kommunikations Geheimnis fight.
Mit diesem kleinen trifft Knip den die hier gemacht haben entsteht eine Speiche Verpflichtung von IP-Adressen von so ungefähr 3 Monaten bis 7 Jahren
je nachdem auf welche Rechtsgrundlage mischt man sie stützt weil Stammdaten müssen schon allein für finanzkunde eigentlich 7 Jahre gespeichert werden.
Und markante daneben auch diese App hier dreisten die daneben ja bis 7 Jahre vorliegen.
Für Verwaltungsverfahren verwenden also für Wald und Wiesen Kriminalität einerseits wo man keinen Richter kann ein Staatsanwalt mehr braucht das kann die Polizei sozusagen.
Direkt mit am anrufe beim Provider machen und das ganze würde eben auch die Möglichkeit eröffnen fürs Urheberrecht auf IP Adressen zuzugreifen.
Erklär mir doch mal warum 7 Jahre Speicherpflicht existiert aus finanzabrechnung.
Haben das ist es es gibt mehr rechts und dann das eine ist sozusagen die Einspruchsfrist dass es weniger das wären so irgendwie die drei bis fünf Monate die das noch eine Rechnung beansprucht aber wenn du deine Buchhaltung.
Amos der gewisse Zeit lang vorhalten und dazu zählt hier im auch das kundenregister.
Also ich störe die Details können wir verlinken in den Stellungnahmen von epicenter works und von denen Internet-Service-Provider nin Österreich wir haben hier irgendwie zusammen agiert bei diesem Thema
und es ist auf jeden Fall eben eine viel längere Speicherung von diesem Daten vorgesehen als dass in Österreich sonst der Fall gewiss.
An das wichtiges hat eben auch dass es einen ganz neuen Delikt Kreis gibt auf denen diese Daten auf einmal
ja diese Daten Firma zugreifen kann also es wäre dann eben wirklich für Wald und Wiesen Kriminalität inklusive gewisse nur Bereich Delikten möglich auf die IP Adressen zuzugreifen und auch den Leuten die hinter den iP-Adressen sind habhaft zu werden.
Da ist ganz wichtig du hast bei so einem Ermittlungsverfahren iP-Adressen sind nicht nur einfach irgendwelche Nummern die dich im Internet
identifizieren sondern in fast jeden Ermittlungs red Astaire zuerst irgendwie den Inhalt findest irgendwo da Server der beschlagnahmt wird oder and orange warm und da findest du diese IP-Adresse.
Damit hast du zuerst den Inhalt und suchst dann nur noch die Person zu dem Inhalt dadurch ist es auch immer an Datenschutz sondern beim Privatsphäre ein.
Was war denn das jetzt für eine Maßnahme also was was ist denn quasi nach der Begutachtung in dieses Telekommunikationsgesetz genau eingesetzt worden.
Also es ist ganz lustig es ist wurde in diesem verlinken das auch Paragraph 92 Ziffer 16A eingeführt
A&E hat jetzt eben eine IP-Adresse definiert.
Und zwar eben nicht mehr eine öffentliche statische IP-Adresse soll man wirklich eine IP-Adresse und da gibt es irgendwie eine schöne Definition.
Und der letzte Satz von diesem dieser Ziffer 16A ist FIFA 16 letzter Halbsatz gilt sinngemäß.
Jetzt muss man sich die Ziffer 16 anschauen das ist die Definition einer öffentlichen IP-Adresse der letzte Satz dort ist
wenn eine konkrete öffentliche IP-Adresse einem Teilnehmer für die Dauer eines Vertrages auch zur ausschließlichen Nutzung zugewiesen ist.
Handelt es sich zugleich um ein Standard um im Sinne des 92 Absatz 3 Ziffer 3 und.
Dieses Eis handelt es sich zugleich um an stammdatum das haben sie sozusagen mit einem Verweis auf den letzten.
Bei der vorherigen Definition hinzugefügt.
Du hast ja mal einfach durch so eine kleine Referenz durch so ein Link quasi aus einer dynamisch zugeteilten IP-Adresse dieselbe dieses Jahr in dieselbe Klasse erhoben wie die statischen und damit quasi dauerhaft speicherbar machen wollen.
Antares ist das Ding irgendwie auf will haben wir uns lange an den Kopf gegriffen und gedacht bitte das kann doch nicht sein dann irgendwie mit viel Recherche auch irgendwie Rechtschreibung auf gearbeitet.
Ja auch verwiesen auf die ist Badi Internet Service Provider Österreich mit denen wir im überwachungs Thema sehr gut zusammenarbeiten
und wir sind dann gemeinsam irgendwie zumindest deren marschiert und haben auch gemeinsam eine Presseaussendung gemacht
zu diesem Thema und am Tag darauf ist die Regierung auch schon zurückgerudert und hat gemeint UPS ist uns passiert und hat es den Verein lassen
also ein schönes Beispiel eigentlich dafür wie man versucht solche Änderungen an der Öffentlichkeit vorbei
in Gesetzen zu verstecken und das eben noch dazu irgendwie recht verklausuliert so dass man es beim ersten drüberlesen nichts nicht sieht
Arm und das ist halt so irgendwie wie wie bei den Vampiren wenn man dann irgendwie mit dem Licht in die Dunkelheit scheint dann
gegen die Fledermäuse weg und in dem Fall haben wir es ganz gut geschafft das einzufangen.
Aber ja also stay vigilance also man muss ja auf jeden Fall den Leuten sehr genau auf die Finger schauen damit solche Sachen nicht durchkommen.
Gut dann bleiben wir in Österreich und dann kann ich gleich was eine schlechte Nachricht hinterher schießen.
Ah jetzt dividiert sich das wieder alles.
Ja also dass das hier ist jetzt wirklich breaking news also die Geschichte ist gestern raus gekommen und hat auch wieder es ist eigentlich schön wir wir gegen den Gesetzgebungsprozess entlang ja wir haben vorher gerade gelernt
Gesetze Gene Begutachtung dass einigt sich die Regierung drauf dann gehen sie ins Parlament im Parlament.
Gehen Sie dann natürlich zuerst durch Ausschüsse und dann erst ins Plenum
und so ist es jetzt passiert das a ein neues Gesetz für Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungen in Österreich im Umweltausschuss eine kleine Änderung erfahren hat
und diese Änderung besagt nämlich wenn du eine Umwelt NGO bist und bei solchen Verfahren über neue.
Oder Staudämme irgendwie mitreden bist weil du dick oder bist oder gibt's Orgelteile die sagen jajaja NGOs müssen bei solchen.
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung angehört werden weil die sind dann wichtiger player
das hat der das Höchstgericht in Europa hergestellt das ist doch der Grund für diese Änderung gerade in Österreich aber was wenn ich hier eben hinein schummeln will ist das endios.
Die sich bei sowas beteiligen wollen mindestens 100 Mitglieder haben müssen und die Daten aller ihrer Mitglieder.
Den staatlichen Stellen offenlegen müssen das heißt du bist irgendwie Mitglied von global2000 oder Greenpeace
das heißt deine Daten London jetzt bei jedem Verfahren bei staatlichen Stellen.
Und die haben damit sozusagen eine komplette Übersicht darüber wer sich in welchen zivilgesellschaftlichen Vereinen engagiert
solche Sachen kennen wir schon es gibt solche Gesetze zum Beispiel in Ungarn da ist es so dass Angie aus dem Asylbereich ihrer Mitgliederlisten gegenüber dem Staat auf den Dingen müssen das erzeugt natürlich einen chilligen effect.
Weil wenn du an Job hast ja der EZB staatsnahe ist oder sie einfach nur du bist Gera oder Kindergarten,
und dann auf einmal kann es sein dass du bisschen staatlichen Stellen bekannt ist dass du dich da und dort irgendwas hier stop.
Könnte man die ja zum Nachteil auslegen du bist vielleicht homosexuell und engagiert sich dort bei der EM giovis aber nicht dass das deine Arbeitgeber weiß
könnte unangenehm werden wenn du mit diesem Engagement dann in irgendeiner Datenbank ab,
ganz unmittelbar dadurch dass diese 100 Mitglieder ja auch geleistet werden müssen Moment gibt es ungefähr 60 bis 70 und Angie aus die sich an solchen Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungen
beteiligen da geht's wirklich und leihen um lokale Sachen also da geht's um um um lokale Flüsse Bäche
Anrainer zum Flughafen die sich gegen eine neue Piste des Flughafen Schwechat wären all diese kleinen NGOs von denen zu 60-70 gibt davon würden ca nur 20 übrig bleiben.
Alle anderen haben gar nicht so viele Mitglieder und diese Mitglieder würden sie glaube ich bekommen wenn sie sich darum bemühen das ist ja etwas wo wo viele Leute unterstützenswert sich auch in die Bresche werfen würden aber trotzdem hier geht's ums Prinzip.
Sowohl um das Datenschutz Prinzip.
Minimierung und dem Missbrauchspotential was mit so einer Weitergabe sofort kommt aber auch eben diesen demokratischen Prinzipien dass du dass der in einer Demokratie dein Engagement nicht nachteilig.
Ausgelegt werden soll und das ist irgendwie schon erscheinen das Gesetz wurde gestern im Umweltausschuss behandelt
und obwohl wir es geschafft haben gemeinsam mit Greenpeace die das ja sehr weit vorne waren das ganze in die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen ist es beschlossen worden.
Amos die Regierung hält daran auch fest also ich hier scheint sie sich nicht zu bewegen.
Greenpeace hart aber auch gleich gesagt also weil die Regierung begründet dieses Gesetz damit dass es sagt diese Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungen die dauern so lange und wir wollen den wie das die schneller vonstattengehen Wind gesagt okay
könnt ihr haben.
Wir werden von jetzt an bei jedem jeder Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung uns daran beteiligen und Einspruch erheben und das Ding muss sozusagen dann über Jahre in die Länge ziehen solange dieses Gesetz gilt in Österreich.
Und das heißt das Thema wird
weiter diskutiert werden und ich hoffe irgendwann wird sich die Regierung hier von ihrem Hardcore Wirtschaftskurs auch wieder abbrechen lassen,
eigentlich hatte ich immer so die Hoffnung dass es ihr nur so die FPÖ ist dir der Machete gänzlich egal ist aber das hier kommt gerade vom ÖVP von konservativ geführten Umwelt Restaurant
von Ministerin Köstinger an die war früher Europaabgeordnete und von dir hat man sich eigentlich auch mehr erwartet dass die hier so eine harte einer Position an den Tag legt ist eigentlich verwunderlich aber.
Muss man was man hatte zugestehen.
Ja erinnert mich auch so also eine ganz fatale Art und Weise an unser letztes Gespräch über diese ganze bvt-affäre ne Oma im Prinzip außer diesen
Eindruck Gewand das so die Rechtsausleger vor allem erstmal versuchen den Apparat dazu zu nutzen feindes Listen zu erstellen
und
sah Inn Minister den ihr da am Freitag Eden habt ihr selber uns bei unseren Hardcore Nazis auch sehr beliebt genau aus diesem Grund gibt es so verschiedene Videos und Vorfälle oder irgendwelche.
Nazis auf der Bühne so schon ankündigen so nach dem Motto ja hier ihr von der Antifa und so Werner.
Polizei filmt Gesichter und dann machen die Listen und wenn wir dann erstmal an der Regierung sind dann hauen wir aber.
Ganz genau deswegen also im Grunde ist das alles im Lehrstück dafür wir so wie er
in einer Demokratie unabhängige staatliche Institutionen brauchen und auch ein Rechtsstaatsprinzip haben
weil weil wir halt eben nicht wollen das staatliches Handeln willkürlich nach politischen winden sich dreht sondern es
braucht da immer eine rechtliche Grundlage ist braucht eine eine Verwaltung die auch unabhängig agieren kann die die die nicht nur nach Willfährigkeit ja ihr Personal aussucht.
Und im Grunde ist Österreich jetzt gerade so richtig schön Beispiel dafür wie wieso diese ganzen Werte wichtig sind ja und.
Donphan dass dass das Datenschutz halt an der Stelle auch wirklich in freiheits Schutz ist manch also ich meine gerade meine.
Willst du nicht so zu his Zuseher historisieren und in die Vergangenheit zurückblicken aber man sich mal anschaut wie diese ganze Bewegung eilig ins Rollen gekommen ist in.
In 80er Jahren war das ja auch also zu müssen Deutschland bis zum 2017.
Deutschsprachigen Bereich ne so schlägt eine Lehre aus der Nazizeit das einfach dieses ganze
Listen bauen und Datenbanken Aufbauen von den Feinden und daneben Prinzip auch das industrielle
abarbeiten dieser Listen also das Vernichten Töten von Menschen,
ein Wesenszug gewesen ist dieses System und das eben auch deshalb diese ganze.
Datenschutz Diskussion mit aufgebracht wurde wenn man einfach aktiv verhindern wollte das genauso eine Kontrolle möglich ist und damals war das sicherlich alles noch.
Anan anan sehr zukunftsgewandt hablick weil.
Man hat ja auch gesehen dass Überwachung vielleicht den 80er Jahren also sag Mama der Kampf dagegen immer so ein bisschen als history auch angesehen wurde weil ja auch gar nicht so viel gemacht werden konnte aber jetzt wo die Preise.
Überwachung immer weiter singen weil die Technologie ist immer weiter ermöglicht sieht man eben auch wie alle.
Loslaufen und jetzt eben das auch alles tun wollen es nicht so weit aus.
Holen hier aber das ist schick natürlich an dieser Stelle auch immer wieder mitgenommen und dieses ganze wir verpflichten euch eure Daten zu geben.
Muss man halt auch immer wieder Bedenken ja und genau solche sensiblen Daten sind heutzutage eben auch wunderbar nutzbar.
Ja und da damals war's noch noch Karten heute ist das alles weil das Fortgeschrittene
aber ich will was du das sagst nur verwenden um ein
häufig verwendetes Gegenargumente entkräften weil was wir ganz oft hören ist dass diese ganzen staatlichen Datensammlungen sind doch kein Problem auf Facebook sind die Leute ja viel freizügiger mit Ihren Daten
an den leiden sehr Datenschützer gar nicht wichtig sonst wären sie können sie gar nicht im Internet unterwegs sein und wenn irgend wieder Google das darf dann darf der Staat es ja auch irgendwie einen kleineren Maße.
Da ist halt einfach an einen einzigen Vierkanter Unterschied.
Es ist ist es schlimm genug dass diese Firmen nicht dazu zwingen Striptease zu machen wenn ich irgendwo im Internet an Ihren Diensten vorbei Schramme aber.
Das sind immer noch bewahrt wirtschaftliche Unternehmen die noch nicht ein Gewaltmonopol haben und als Staat eine viel tiefere einen Krebs macht in mein Leben haben
und ja es gibt die Fälle dass diese privaten Daten dann auch tat ich genutzt werden siehe Noten und
die Programme die wo wo auch auf die Daten der privaten zugegriffen wird oder.
Und historisch zu werden Mussolini Anton fashion is the merger of the state with
bekommt man ist also ja das ist drin hat immer auch irgendwie Wechselseitigkeit and aber es ist ein ganz großer Unterschied aber ich meine Daten jetzt einem Unternehmen gebe wo ich mich immer noch in einer Kaufentscheidung
dagegen entscheiden kann oder wenn es Gesetze gibt die mich dazu verpflichten dass meine Daten irgendwo landen.
Und was was hier gesagt werden muss ist in Österreich ist es heute schon so wenn man einer steuerlich begünstigten Organisation spendet.
Ah das war irgendwie so ein Zeitpunkt wo wo wir es Verein noch ganz jung waren und uns noch nicht irgendwie einbrennen konnten aber leider ist es in Österreich so wenn man.
Lautester Ton spendet die steuerlich begünstigt ist spricht diese Spende kann ich mir meiner Steuererklärung begünstigender anmerken dann muss dieser Organisation meine Daten ans Finanzministerium Melk.
Was heißt das Finanzministerium hat eine ständig aktualisierte Liste mit den Spenderinnen und Spendern von.
Fast allen Angie aus in Österreich
wir fallen nicht unter die Sperre die die die steuerliche Begünstigung weil da muss man irgendwie sich um Entwicklungshilfe Kinder oder Altenpflege kümmern und Demokratie und Grundrechte sind nicht förderungswürdig in Österreich
aber das ist auch etwas wo diese Listen sozusagen heute schon in Teilen existieren und die Spenderin sind natürlich noch mal niederschwellige hast die wirklichen Mitglieder von Umweltorganisationen warum sitzt hier.
Ja bleiben wir immer im Takt Überwachung gab's auch von privacy international was ist denn da passiert.
Also das ist falsch international sind unsere Kollegen aus Auskunft Italien das ist eine NGO die sich seit vielen vielen Jahren um den
Datenschutz und Privatsphäre kümmert ähnlich Amnesty International haben sie irgend globalen Anspruch die haben auch wirklich großes Büro und und und sehr gute Josten Gerüsten die sind
auch mit vielen Klagen an Höchstgerichte beschäftigt machen studieren und sind insgesamt zu einer der größten Datenschutz Angie aus der Welt würde ich sagen und
artis international war kürzlich auch in den Medien weil sie es geschafft haben mit einem,
höchste richtigen Urteil Teile von den britischen überwachungsgesetz and die sogenannte snoopers Charter zurücknehmen zulassen nicht gab ihr habt darüber auch in Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtet.
Und ja was eben aber diese Woche rauskam ist,
pipes International selbst überwacht wurde von den Geheimdienst,
Ingos Bethanien insbesondere dem Inlandsgeheimdienst ermal five aber scheinbar auch andere,
cybersix und ICE AGE you dürften auch ihre Foundation oder an anderen Teil der Operation überwacht haben
unser das Ganze kam nicht ganz zusammen ich glaube aufgrund von einem investkraft Haustyp you'll also diesen,
die Lichtung Pfeiffer Court in den USA diesem Gremium Wurm Gerhard.
7 geheimen geheimen Gerichten.
Genau und da stehe ich Ihnen sie irgendwie Zugriff gehabt zu haben auf dieser Informationen und
dadurch haben sie jetzt eben herausgefunden dass sie selber auch von dieser Überwachung betroffen waren und rufe natürlich auch gleich dazu auf.
Das jetzt politische Konsequenzen haben muss sehen dass auch als Beleg für ihre Kritik an diesen
ausufernden überwachungs Befugnissen weil wenn Geheimdienst der gehen kann und die Zivilgesellschaft überwachen kann dann glaube ich finden kann man schon sagen okay hier ist eine Grenze überschritten und ich habe eindeutig zu wenig Kontrolle und Rechtfertigung
und Japan Fuji irgendwie dazu auf den home secretary etwas zutun insgesamt ich.
Wenig Hoffnung dass im britischen
bitte schon Gefüge dass ich dass mir zumindest derzeit da stellt sich da groß was tun wird es ist auf jeden Fall noch mal einen Stein in der Mauer der zeigt wie wie gefährlich unkontrollierte Geheimdienste sind,
und dass sie wirklich so dass Demokratie Freiräume in einer Demokratie immer zu Missbrauch Alter.
Ja ich denke die britische Politik Klasse ist derzeit ausreichend mit sich selber beschäftigt um
Kindergarten gesamten Landes wie noch zu verhindern oder eigentlich sind betreiben sie ihn gerade und irgendwann müssen Sie mal anfangen das zu verhindern sodass ich auch wenig Hoffnung habe das jetzt hier in unserer formen
gerade viele regulierendes passiert also durften glaube ich diese Operation ja weiter freidrehen weil er woanders liegt.
Besondere die Aufmerksamkeit der.
Ja aber das nie Material was konnte Theresa May inzwischen produziert ist legendär also die Frau wird zwar sich nicht in den Geschichtsbüchern gut wegkommen aber sie wird viele viele internet-memes haben die an sie erinnern.
Ich hoffe noch das aber sie noch verklagt.
Ja beim tolle Parteitag hat Asia irgendwie sie auf die Bühne gelaufen in einer sehr,
stochastischen Art und Weise wie eine Marionette das aber zu einem Europe Hop Song was auch irgendwie.
Niemand so richtig erklären konnte wieso.
Ja das ist alles wirklich also im Bereich fremdschämen ist die angelsächsische Welt gerade wirklich uneinholbar vorne die USA wirklich noch unbedingt auf Platz eins aber UK ist definitiv
Roller ab und danach kommt erstmal ne ganze Weile lang nicht.
So aber schauen wir in die USA.
Apropos USA.
Da gibt's oben die Netzneutralität die ist ja nach wie vor umstritten weil die trump-regierung gerne Verschärfung durchsetzen möchte dabei aber noch nicht so weit vorangekommen ist wie es ist.
Ja also die.
In den USA gab es Entwicklungen wir erinnern uns der der Ausgangszustand ist Jena dass die Obama Ära
Nettetal ETC Regeln aus 2015 von der Trump Regierung 2017 zurückgenommen wurden
mit einem sehr wunderbaren Rechtsakte seiner FSI Entscheidung Mystery Internet freedom haben sie das damals genannt,
The Voice peace und das hat natürlich zu sehr viel ging Reaktionen geführt den Datennetz Alkalität wegzunehmen
ist etwas dass es auch in Europa irgendwie für Wirbel gesorgt hat wir hatten teilweise fast mehr Berichterstattung über diese Entscheidung in den USA als wir in Europa hatten
über unsere eigenen Regeln dass sie geschrieben wurden.
Und ich glaube es gab dann mehrere Bundesstaaten in den USA die Regeln zu nett Zentralität erlassen haben.
Das waren aber hauptsächlich Gesetze die nur so einen Teil der alten Regeln wieder hergestellt haben
teilweise ging es bei diesem bundesstaatlichen Gesetzen auch nur darum in öffentlichen Vergabeprozess Netzneutralität aus ein Ausschreibungskriterien für Internetanschlüsse von Schulen über,
Eaton Amtsgebäuden festzuschreiben und so an gewissen Druck aufzubauen damit
die öffentlichen Behörden und und da wo man vielleicht auch viber den Leuten anbietet ist dort wenigstens doch nicht Sakralität gibt
das ganze was sicherlich auch so Symbolpolitik aber eben auch mit dem Versuch zu sagen wir wollen den Internetprovider die Sache nicht so einfach machen
wenn jetzt anfangen derzeit Realität auszuhöhlen müssen sie immernoch Nettetal etait anbieten zumindest von Teil des mag das
das war so ungefähr die Ausgangslage nebenher gibt noch einige Gerichtsprozesse gegen diese Entscheidung der FCC von 2000.
Aber diese Woche gab es eine große Neuentwicklung nämlich das Kalifornien
ein Gesetz verabschiedet hat das wirklich den Großteil der.
Nettetaler geht's Regen wiederherstellt oder das Volk der stark den 2015er
FCC Regeln also ist echte ne Zentralität vollumfänglich die USA vorher hat.
Jetzt hier wieder in Kalifornien Geld und dieses Gesetz wurde jetzt auch von den Kammern das Parlament verabschiedet und vom
Coppeneur unterschrieben ist also jetzt in Effekt und natürlich sofort hat die Trump Regierung angekündigt dagegen zu klagen.
Wieso ist das jetzt hier so ein Streitpunkt nicht nur weil das Gesetz besser ist als die vorherigen sondern auch weil California eigentlich der größte Markt
in den USA ist also
wenn du dir die die Größe der hat also die Menschen die dort leben und auch wie viel Grad ausgeben da ist er auch sie noch sehr viele Internetfirmen ansässig in Kalifornien natürlich dann ist das schon ein großer Brocken dir hier raus fällt
Kerstin eisbiest wiederum sehr schwierig machen würde vielleicht entdecken von der Netzneutralität abzurücken sie müssten dann zumindest deine Doppelgleisigkeit fahren
und innerhalb der USA kannst du türlich dann auch ganz leicht passieren dass Leute von anderen Bundesstaaten sich einfach eine kalifornische SIM-Karte holen,
für die dann ne Zentralität gelten muss auch wenn sie in anderen Teilen des Landes unterwegs sind also so ein Forum shopping wäre möglich.
Ja und wie gesagt die Farben Regierungen der gefällt das überhaupt nicht Jeff sessions der Justizminister kann man sagen.
Schon eine Klage dagegen eingereicht die hat ja schon in der Schublade und man versucht jetzt hier sozusagen Kalifornien als Beispiel Herr zu nehmen dass dieser
Entscheidung auf federal level eben nicht von der Bundesstaaten unterminiert werden darf
was auch in ganz interessante Argumentation ist für die republikanische Partei
ja immer gesagt hat wir wollen so wenig federal government wie möglich und am besten am liebsten ist und wenn es alles auf bundesstaatlicher Ebene geregelt wird.
Antje macht man eine 180 Grad Kehrtwende und sagt nein nein nein nein nein wir müssen das auf jeden Fall erleben für die ganzen USA regeln.
Was auch irgendwie da gibt's schöne kommentar von IMVU dem Erfinder des Begriffs Netzneutralität ja dass das amerikanische Perspektive
beleuchtet
und was was ich auch noch ganz spannend finde ist das AT bei der 2. Vorsitzender der Regulierungsbehörde FCC er sagt doch ganz klar wir brauchen diese Abschaffung von Dezentralität.
Investitionsanreize für 5g zu schaffen also 5g der neue Mobilfunkstandard der
irgendwann vielleicht einmal kommen wird und halt schneller als 4G und LTE sein wird
das ist das Argument was wir auch hier in Europa ganz oft hören das 5g diese neue Technologie von der man sich Milch und Honig verspricht mit dir auf einmal alle Internet Probleme gelöst werden auch in Deutschland
großer Hai Versprechungen was feiert man da.
Sogar in Deutschland kranerwirt Internet Probleme lösen.
Ja ich habe nicht immer so diese diese tollen Mobilfunkmasten die müssen ja eigentlich mit ganz viel Glasfaser angebunden sein um die Daten vom mastern auch wieder zurückzubringen ins restliche Internet.
Dieses Glas könnte man jetzt schon verlegen sollte man vielleicht damit anfangen.
Ja komm jetzt nicht so nicht so mach mal nicht so wie Thermik hier das geht ja alles sein bedächtigen Gang.
Wo drüber nachgedacht werden.
Also
ich ich Kurzzeit sorry aber ich war ja im im in Deutschland Wirtschaftsministerium als ich in Berlin war und zu einem braunen Dialog zum Telekommunikationsgesetz bisweilen wie ganz lustig das war so wie ein Uni Hörsaal 60 Leute,
es war irgendwie zwei Leute von der Fahrzeit Befahren von den Konsumenten schützen und ich da drinne und sonst nur Industrie
und es gibt ja im deutschen Koalitionsvertrag auch so dieses Grund dieses Recht auf
Breitbandversorgung was einklagbar sein soll er an Mann ist er in der Tagesordnung wirklich Trinkgeld über alle Teile dieses
Gesetzes durchgegangen was hat die große TKG Novelle in Deutschland werden und der allerletzte. War irgendwie so dieses Grundrecht auf Internet und das war so ich glauben hätte so fünf Minuten.
Gesprächszeit dem Thema eingeräumt also ich will mich nicht drauf verlassen dass sich also bald etwas an diesem Thema ändern.
Ich darf auch nicht drauf verlassen also da kann man schon in Bitcoin investieren als irgendwie als auf Bandbreiten Ausbau in Deutschland zu sein.
Jede bringen sie nicht auf Ideen mit der blockchain wird der Netzausbau endlich in Ordnung kommen.
Magaluf droht.
Hör auf jeden Fall 5g wir haben keine Lösung für das Problem außer dass man viel früher hätte anfangen müssen und halt endlich Gas in der Erde verlegt oder am besten an die Mauern tackert weil dann ist es billiger.
Zurück zur NS Neutralität also das ist halt
du dich wieder so ein paar real Argument und alle wissen die eigentlich eine halbwegs ein Deck haben wissen auch man muss die jetzt für 5 kg eilig keine Motivation schaffen das ist vollkommen klar dass wenn man irgendwie als Provider überhaupt in diesem Markt
den will das 5g quasi der Ausbau muss einfach stattfinden es heißt nicht dass es nicht.
Keine Anreize geben sollte natürlich aber die gibt es halt an Dich,
schon als Miss muss man nicht die Netzneutralität dafür opfert das halt immer wieder dieses alte Problem die großen Telekommunikations Profiler hätten
stört sozusagen das über ihre Netze Geld verdient wird und sie daran nicht mitverdienen und genau das soll ja dieses Aufweichen der Netzneutralität bewirken und dann sind wir halt diese Diskriminierung und sozialen diese Geiselnahme von Datenleitung so nach dem Motto naja schönen Dienst haben sie da.
Aber wir können ja Ihnen auch irgendwie mal eine Drossel aufdrücken etc und am besten verkaufen wir quasi beide Richtungen ne also wir verkaufen sozusagen den Zugang vom Anbieter zum Kunden
ja teurer ne damit irgendwie da die Daten auch,
komm und gleichzeitig verkaufen wir aber auch den Zugang vom Kunden zu den Anbietern entsprechend teurer weil wir an der Stelle auch noch mal diskriminieren weil dass das ist das Grundprinzip von der Missachtung von
Netzneutralität und deswegen ist es uns ja auch so wichtig auf Netzneutralität zu bringen weil das einfach diesen kompletten mag kaputt macht
weil es viele Implikation hat nicht nur auf der wirtschaftlichen Ebene und was so den Netzausbau und so weiter betrifft so das hat eben auch Implikationen auf die Freiheit von Angeboten den die Zugangsmöglichkeiten zu Angeboten und eben das Ausschließen von,
von Inhalten auf Basis irgendwelche Gründe primär SS getragen vom Geld aber da würde es eben auch nicht stehen.
Am
MSA kingsman zuzufügen was ist ist genau diese Wegelagerei und das ist halt eben auch diese Monetarisierung von Knappheit.
Bei streamon assist Sound und bei Vodafone Pass ist es ja scheinbar wir wissen es nicht genau so dass es da keine Zahlungen der Diensteanbieter gibt aber dafür im zumindest Vodafone extra Geld von den Kunden dafür dass sie in YouTube verkaufen
alles können sie nur machen weil die Datenvolumen insgesamt zu niedrig sind
selbiges bei der Deutschen Telekom eigentlich müsste man immer nur irgendwie Streaming nutzen zu können die Volumen mal mindestens verzehnfachen aber anstatt das zu tun sagt man irgendwie ja alle Dienste anbieter können zu mir kommen und dadurch
die Volumen bleiben insgesamt niedrig in ganz Deutschland aber bei mir habt ihr dann die Dienste dir wollt und so ist meine Marktposition gegenüber der Kundin Kundenverständnis
das ist halt eine neue Version von diesem Geschäftsmodell der Wegelagerei im Grunde.
Mikkelvik mir doch mal jetzt spezifisch auf die EU Situationen dann würde mich das jetzt auch mal interessieren weil ihr wart ja also be handyhörer von obwohl es wirklich wissen du warst ja gerade was dieses Aushandeln der Netzneutralität Vereinbarung in der EU betrifft
extrem aktiv haben wir ja hier auch ausführlich darüber berichtet über dein Engagement idrijca und ihr wart ja eigentlich am Ende relativ
zufrieden mit dem Ergebnis frage ich mal ne oder hat zumindest das recht optimistisch gesehen seitdem gab es einig
diverse Rückschritte z.b. eben mit Simon et cetera wie steht ihr denn dazu wie und wie wie ist dieser aktuelle auseinander.
Genau also ich glaube um diese Frage zu beantworten ich würde dann in die Zukunft schauen aber eigentlich gibt's dann wunderbarer Frage auch von dem Nutzer
Pfarrer der sich gerade eben im Park bezüglich Portugal fragt wieso was da mit deiner Zentralität in Einklang zu bringen ist weil es ist doch ein EU Gesetz und das müsste doch auch in Portugal.
Selber hast du Gard mit Simon gesagt in Deutschland das Problem ist hier die Regulierungsbehörde hat bei Zero Rating extrem viel Entscheidungsgewalt an dem Grunde ist es wirklich der Behörde überlassen zu welcher Entscheidung sie kommt
A und das Grundproblem ist müsste ich ja eigentlich mal eine eine Behörde verklagen weil im Moment versuchen Sie sich alle weg zu ducken und der Industrie möglichst wenig Regeln vorzuschreiben auch wenn diese Produkte klar schlecht für das Internet und den Wettbewerb sind
H&M zero-rating haben wir einfach im enforcement in der Rechtsdurchsetzung immer noch wahnsinnige Probleme in Euro.
Und ich glaube dass wir in dem anderen Thema Spezialdienste was auch noch irgendwie nicht ganz so perfekt gelöst ist mit 5.
Dann Probleme bekommen werden
ein vor diesem Hintergrund wird jetzt aber in Europa bereits nächstes Jahr wieder an der Reform dieser Regeln gebastelt
das ganze hat zwei Seiten einerseits die wirkliche Rechtsgrundlage die wird gerade geändert,
am und das ist wahrscheinlich etwas das also der hat der Bericht der EU-Kommission
für das Gesetz was nächste Tollitäten Europafest schreibt die Telefon binnenmarktverordnung dir muss bis April 2019 veröffentlicht werden und wir sind alle sehr gespannt auf diesen Bericht weil die Kommission ist eigentlich eher
zu deiner zentrale
und dieser dieser Evaluierungsbericht ist sozusagen die Grundlage macht man das Gesetz jetzt auf oder belässt man es so wie es ist.
Arm und wenn man das Gesetz aufmacht dann stehen wir schon ähnlich wie in den USA wahrscheinlich von so einem soft Püppi Eltern werden sicherlich teile deine Zentralität.
Rausgeschnitten um Platz für 5g zu machen auch wenn es dafür fachlich überhaupt kein Grund gibt aber die Bedrohung ist ja real und das ist auch das was ich ständig hören.
Am und Wald ist Evaluierung ebenso Heike ist hat die EU-Kommission sich dazu entschieden die auszuschreiben,
und einen annanan Vergabeprozess zu machen muss ja einfach gar sagen das ist der berichten wir uns wünschen dieses fact-finding man muss mit den ganzen Stakeholdern reden
andasol hat wirklich ein möglichst guter Bericht sein damit wir unsere Entscheidung treffen können wie wir das Gesetz bewerten und ob wir es neu aufmachen kann ja nur die Kommission machen
und ja diese Ausschreibung hat gewonnen die Anwaltsfirma aus den Niederlanden bird and bird,
finanztools ganze Liebe Firma mit Büros überall auf der Welt überhaupt ansässig in den Niederlanden und ja.
Hast du gehört haben dass diese Firma das bekommen hat waren wir recht erstaunt weil Bert und Bert ist bekannt weltweit die Telekom Industrie zu fett.
Bei Rechtsstreitigkeiten mit Regulierungsbehörden mit Fokus auf Netzneutralität
also diese Firma ist wirklich dafür bekannt sie eigentlich dttz relativ wo es geht angreift und die wurden jetzt von der Kommission mit der
Evaluierung dieses Gesetzes beauftragt wir haben unsere Nummer auch von dem Brief gemeinsam mit
bitte Frieda masoneilan edry und vielen anderen NGOs an die Kommission gewendet zum,
Reisbach conflict of interest vielleicht also gibt's hier Interessenskonflikte ist es nicht irgendwie problematisch wenn der Bock zum Gärtner gemacht wird und übrigens wenn Regulierungsbehörden inaktiver Rechtsstreitigkeit
Telekom Konzernen sind die vertreten werden von dieser Anwaltskanzlei dann haben die vielleicht ein Problem ganz offen und ehrlich zu sein mit derselben Anwaltskanzlei.
Am vor allem weil die halt wirklich auch viele Daten und Fakten und ökonomische Dinge Abfragen also die Dinger die so die die Vorstufe der Entscheidung von Behörden sind.
Die Kommission hat Tank geantwortet mit einem Brief vom mehrwertiger drinsteht
was ist ein ganz normaler Vorgang überhaupt nichts zu sehen gehen Sie weiter.
Und so eine conflict of interest Klausel im Vergabeprozess in das können wir nicht machen weil damit würden ja qualifizierte Teilnehmer,
ausgeschlossen werden nur weil jemand in dem Thema arbeitet heißt es ja nicht dass der nicht neutral sein kann.
Diese Anwaltskanzlei die hat ja die hat uns zugesichert dass sie eine Firewall eingerichtet hat
ja also das innerhalb der Anwaltskanzlei die Leute nicht miteinander reden wir haben dann nachgeschaut die Personen die an der Evaluierung beteiligt sind die Personen die gerade
bei dem bei dem Rechtsstreit rundum Netzneutralität mit diesem Mobile Niederlanden zu dem dortigen streamon pro Paket involviert sind
beide Personen sitzen in der Kanzlei in Rotterdam.
Sprich da gibt es auf jeden Fall mal ein Mittagessen oder so wo die sich begegnen und
die dürfen halt dann auf keinen Fall über diese Fälle reden und dass das ist so Dizzy Versicherung die man uns da gegeben hat
A&E jagten die die die Anwaltskanzlei AG wurde aber jetzt von der Kommission auferlegt in dieser finalen Studie
alle potentiellen conflict of interest offenzulegen also das ist die einzige gute Sache bei der Geschichte.
Das wird lernen werden wo die denn noch so überall betätigt sind weil wir keine natürlich nur ein Teil der Fälle wo aus den,
NGOs und Behörden dir keine Leute involviert sind wir haben uns dann auf jeden Fall noch mal an die Kommission gewendet mit
nein dann bin ich und es ist jetzt insbesondere wichtig dass die Kommission ja die letztliche Verantwortung hat die kann sich da nicht abputzen einen umso
besseren und neutrale Rennbericht veröffentlicht im April und das ganze ist halt kein
gutes Vorzeichen unter dem die Reform der Zentralität in Europa steht
ich gehe davon aus dass vieles noch von der Europawahl abhängen wird wir haben Mai 2019 Wahlen in Europa und wahrscheinlich ist das so einer der wichtigsten Wahlen
syngear zu der man gehen wird
und auf jeden Fall hingehen und auf jeden Fall irgendwie auch nicht politisch wählen und nach Bürgerrechts Perspektive wählen
am Ball das nächste Parlament sicher großräumig verändern wird schon allein durch brexit aber auch Weile einige klassische linke Parteien wegfallen werden andere kommen dazu manche Parteien werden sich anderen Parteien Familien
zuordnen wie z.b. macrons insgesamt wird es ja spannender
und ich glaube erst danach werden wir sehen wer Sitzen im Parlament.
Wer wird denn der neue digitalkommissar kriegen wir so jemanden wie Günter Ettinger wieder oder oder Windows gute Leute die Ahnung haben.
Und je nachdem glaube ich wirds dann wird man sich entweder trauen das Gesetz aufzumachen.
Oder was wir jetzt schon auf jeden Fall wissen was passieren wird ist die Beere guidelines die waren auf jeden Fall aufgemacht also die regulatorische Umsetzung dieses Gesetz ist das warum wir zuletzt in 2016 zu hart gestritten haben das wird so oder so
nächstes Jahr noch mal
reformiert und das heißt dadurch gibt's auch auf jeden Fall wieder bessere Qualität Team Didi dividiere.
Messer rasiert ist eine Richtlinie.
Eine Verordnung also direkt anwendbar.
Es ist eine Verordnung die aber trotzdem nationalen Spielraum bietet.
Nur in den Strafbestimmungen genau ansonsten ist alles in der Verordnung selber geregelt.
Am und unter ja also eigentlich das ist insofern schön gemacht und musste nur die Telekom binnenmarktverordnung lesen Artikel.
34 und 35 alles über netto Tollität in Europa das sind glaube ich
344 Seiten das war es bei den Strafbestimmungen ist das eben die Mitgliedstaaten überlassen kann immer mal verlinken wir haben mal komplett zusammen gesammelt wie hoch diese Strafen sind in ganz Europa Deutschland.
Genau gesagt noch mal diese drei vier Seitenwände vielleicht auch mal verlinken die man dann nur lesen muss ne.
Das ist das ist auch wirklich nicht nicht schwer die bergei sonst kann man auch noch lesen dass es so die kommentierte Fassung davon
und nur noch zu den Straßen wärmstes auch angeschaut wie hoch die eigentlich sind und Deutschland ist dann 19 Stelle in deiner maximal Strafe von 501000 €
die die dazu leisten ist immer gegen die Netzneutralität verstößt Physio Rating gibt es gar keine Strafe
das hat der Gesetzgeber irgendwie gesagt nein wollen wir nicht dass es dafür einen Preis der gibt und für streamon was ja eine klare.
Zero Rating Zero Strafe.
Ja
Es ist aufjedenfall SodaStream an gibt sehr viele Sachen zu kritisieren aber eine Sache die ganz klar rechtswidriges ist diese Drosselung von Video auf DVD Qualität und auch da hat die die.
Bundesnetzagentur nur eine Maximalstrafe als eine Strafe von 101000 € verhängt.
Das heißt sie haben nur irgendwie ein Fünftel davon ausgeschöpft überhaupt für etwas das ganz genau europarechtswidrig ist
und das perfide das habe ich auch im Wirtschaftsminister haben so gesagt ist wenn man sich anschaut es gibt bei der Deutschen Telekom einen extremen Kundenschwund
innenlaufende lightings links und rechts weg egal wie Mobilfunk oder im Festnetz der einzige Bereich wo sie einen Zustrom haben an Kunden ist der Hybrid Bereich also leitet die sowohl Mobilfunk.
Wir festnetz haben wenn wir jetzt die man sich mal anschaut man hat überall diese leidige Drossel auf DVD Qualität die karopa rechtswidrig ist.
Außer bei den Hybrid Kunden die magentaeins Kunden das sind die einzigen.
Nicht unter draußen leiden die auch eine HD Video-Streaming bekommen von YouTube und Netflix von allen und genau die,
wo wo wahrscheinlich in der normalen römische Umsatz gemacht wurde dafür hat
target ist eine maximal Strafe von 101000 € also das ist auch also da merkt man schon irgendwie die die Aktienanteile des deutschen Staates irgendwie das damit sehr sanften Handschuh dieses Unternehmen angegriffen wird um ja nicht in eigenem Beteiligungen Zuschauer.
Genug Netz verteilt.
So das bringt uns zu den Kurzmeldungen.
Wir brauchen auch noch eine Klingel.
Das stimmt was vollkommen unter Dschungeltier alles zunächst einmal duzen Reisewarnung.
Für Neuseeland sein ganzes Land sein habe ich gehört ich wollte eigentlich auch schon immer mal hin aber
die machen es einem nicht einfach denn jetzt gab es ein neues Gesetz was sie sich ausgedacht haben nehme ich der customs and excise act
2018 und der Erlaubnis den Zollbehörden Ausländern bei der Einreise die für eine Entsperrung erforderlichen Daten.
Für Smartphones oder andere elektronische Geräte abzuluchsen sprich wenn man dahin kommt.
Und die sagen so noch hier du siehst aber mal echt für dich dich aus wir brauchen jetzt mal schnell mal ein Blick auf dein iPhone dann fragen die mal frech nachdem Passcode.
Ungenannt einzutippen und sich daher forensisch mit dem telefon zu vergnügen.
Dürfen zwar wenig kaputt machen aber dürfen auf jeden Fall mit Hilfsmitteln drauf naja.
Denkt was ich so na ja Gott was wollen mit meinem Passwort wenn man das ablehnt.
Dann wird nicht nur diese Gerät einbehalten sondern man kann dann auch noch mit einer Strafe von bis zu 5000 neuseeländischen was das Dollar oder Pfund.
Scheiße noch mal gleich die lokale Währung da egal wie auch immer für was ist das unfair so 2850 Euro wie kann man dann auferlegt bekommen wenn man sich dagegen wehrt.
Was hat sich jetzt nicht unbedingt zu der beste Einstieg in einen schönen Urlaub ist.
Ja und sie meinen 7er auch nur lokal drauf suchen und nicht in der Cloud keine Ahnung was sie dann damit machen ob sie das Telefon dann quasi sind Quarantäne Situationen bringen oder wie Sie sich das vorstellen
wird auch auf mich nicht sonderlich beruhigen diese Formulierung letztes Jahr gabs wohl schon
540 Untersuchung von Geräten an neuseeländischen Flughäfen zumindest
das ist ja alles so der Premiere Einfalls Ort da ich den Gemeinden helfen durfte da nicht so viel laufen und naja man wird auch.
Mit entsprechend Beschwichtigungen hier ausgestattet wenn man sich damit beschäftigt weil die Behörden bräuchten ja einen angemessenen Grund und das wäre dann sowas wie kinderausbeutung
Drogenschmuggel
terroristische Aktivitäten das übliche man kennt das ne weil man möchte ja gerne der organisierten Kriminalität etwas entgegensetzen den diese Gruppen aus diesem Bereich
Genia bei dem Versuch Dinge über die Grenze zu bekommen immer raffinierter vor also.
Ja schade eigentlich ich meine Neuseeland wäre ich ein schönes Land
ja um es mal zu bereisen aber irgendwie und nachdem nach dem Bundestrojaner Gesetz jetzt in Australien oder diesen neuen Zugriffs Gesetz was wir irgendwie auch in einer Sendung da vorne besprochen haben irgendwie schaden,
tun die das wegen den ganzen tätigen Valley Milliardären die dort Irland aufkaufen und irgendwie fernzuhalten.
Ja keine Ahnung oder wegen den geflohenen deutschen möchte gerne Hackern die da sich irgendwelche Schlösser bauen.
Also ich denke mal die organisierte Kriminalität wird sich hier ins Fäustchen lachen und sie fühlt sich von dieser Maßnahme sicherlich nicht sonderlich beeindrucken lassen
dass ich jetzt auch die Frage was macht man wenn man jetzt trotzdem nach Neuseeland will weil ehrlich gesagt habe ich es gar keinen bock mir eine potenzielle Reise damal verunglimpfen zu lassen,
auch wenn es das in gewisser Hinsicht schon tut nicht dass ich jetzt irgendwie der Meinung bin.
Unbedingt im Fadenkreuz irgendwelcher Ermittlungen im Punkte holt der genannten Verbrechens Kategorien zu sein nur
Drogenschmuggel kann man jetzt sozusagen mal jedem vorwerfen und schwups hat man dann eben diesen Anspruch und keine Ahnung wie sehr das dann begründet werden muss man muss ich ja klar machen Neuseeland ist Teil der Fall weiß also im verbunden in USA
Großbritannien Australien Kanada und wenn halt innerhalb dieses
Systems quasi eine Liste existiert wo man dann drauf ist aus welchen Gründen auch immer dann dürfte das sicherlich auch ausreichen um solche Gesetze zu aktivieren
machen wir uns in dem Moment nichts vor sprich immernoch Neuseeland fährt was macht man.
Komplette gewagtes.
Entweder gar kein Gerät mitnehmen und sich da alles kaufen
und dann aktivieren oder man hat einfach nur ein gewagtes oder irgendwie mit dem Fake Account ausgestattetes Gerät ja also man macht sich quasi für sein iphone einfach so eine zweite Apple ID.
Und keine Ahnung speichert da die Adresse vom Apple Store und.
Sonsteby nichts und irgendwie ein gefakten Twitter-Account Pipapo einfach so eine Alternativ Reise Identität und.
Dann kann man ja auch gerne den Passcode hergeben und.
Wenn man einen quasi eingereist ist baut man sich das Ding wieder und stellt sein die weiß halt aus einem Internet Backup wieder her wenn man sich sicher ist dass man da.
Sprechen sicheren Zugang hat.
Ja du das ist ihr richtig gesagt also ich ich glaube
nur ein gewagtes Gerätes wahrscheinlich dann noch gefährlicher weißer Aufsehen erregt und
was war mich das insgesamt erinnert natürlich auch das sind sich Österreich in Deutschland inzwischen sehr ähnlich wer heute als geflüchteter in dieser Länder kommt muss auch seine Geräte abgeben und die werden auch forensisch analysiert ich weiß nicht ob es da auch mit Pass also mit Passwort Herausgabe
geht aber im Zweifelsfall wird dann einfach der Asylantrag nicht bearbeitet oder genehmigt wenn man nicht operiert
1a ja auch da ist wahrscheinlich ein gewagtes Gerät eine ganz schlechte Idee sondern verbraucht dann halt irgendwie den dazugehörigen Facebook-Account um um überhaupt
gab abzumachen dass man die Person ist die Garde da vorne
Ledersorte sind sehr bedenkliche Tendenzen und Diebe treffen uns alle.
Gut dann war das schlechte Nachrichten oder nein gute Nachrichten ich habe nichts lustiges aus Österreich und zwar
wir wir wir sind ja eine Nation des dunklen Humors also wenn der Teufel existiert er ist definitiv Wiener
und es gibt diese wunderbare Künstlergruppe monochrom.
Geht nicht kennt die sind wirklich kultige Zeit in Ewigkeiten also seit den Uhrzeiten des Internets wer schonmal archiv.org verwendet hat
Kirche wo die an Server stehen wurde von Johannes grenzfurthner von monochrom entweiht sozusagen man hab den einen Gott ausgetrieben mit einer Zeremonie mit ganz vielen
dann die machen wirklich kreativen scheiß und die sind sehr internetaffine und machen auch von von Büchern bis Filmen nicht mehr Webseite und und und und Speichen Nazis irgendwie also die machen wirklich viel wir verlinken die noch aber es sieht,
unter anderem auch eine politische Sache.
Ferlinka im übrigen auch noch den CAE Nummer 62 monochrom ich habe ja mit dem
jetzt Fortnite zumindest bis zum Zeitpunkt vor 10 Jahren stelle ich gerade fest 2008 mal schon sein bis dahin gültige Gesamtwerk analysiert das lässt tief blicken seitdem ist er nicht sehr viel leiser geworden.
Ja also die rennautobett ist B8 Baujahr aufjedenfall eine Sache die
ja die monochrom auch jedes Jahr abhält ist der Wolfgang Lorenz gedenkpreis Wolfgang Lorenz war ehemaliger ORF Programm direkt
Thora und als solche hat er sich 2008
na dieses Jahres theres mal am Fernsehen auf eine schöne Aussage hinreißen lassen dass die Jugendlichen die diese scheiß Internet,
und dieses scheiß Internet wurde ihm als eine atypische Kulturpessimismus ausgelegt und es gibt seit
diese Aussage 2008 geben jedes Jahr diesen Wolfgang Lorenz gedenkpreis der auch als scheiß Internetpreis bezeichnet wird und der wird eben vergeben an diejenigen die sich besonders Kulturpessimist durch mit dem Internet auseinandersetzen und dieses Jahr ging
Preis wie könnte es anders sein an Axel Voss den Berichterstatter für die das Urheberrechtsgesetz,
Upload filtern und Leistungsschutzrecht und Soße und Axel Voss hat hier glaube ich sehr zurecht diesen Preis bekommen der Publikumspreis des volo 2018 ging wie könnte es anders sein Andy schwarz.
Bundesregierung und ich les mal kurz vor aus der Laudatio der Jury Bundeskanzler Sebastian Kurz und sein Kabinett,
treiben Digitalisierung beinahe ausschließlich für die Industrie Bürgerinnen und Bürger sind in diesen Bestrebungen bestenfalls Lieferanten an und Lieferanten von da.
Ich bestehe darauf dass dass dass das auch alles im im breitesten österreichische publiziert.
Weil wenn ich so scheiß Internet höre dann kriegt das gesehen deutscher ich mir jetzt so Muffins ich werde jetzt nicht versuchen den Dialekt zu imitieren.
Scheiß Internet scheiß Inter.
Aber so würde ich im breitesten oberösterreichisch.
Ich wette Johannes grenzfurthner diese sich breitschlagen für einen Dschungel oder so.
Sonst fragen wir ja sonst fragen wir bei dir ich mich.
Er wird dein Thema.
Ja was soll ich auch noch mal erwähnen wollte weil ich dass ich das einfach schon immer nervt sind ja gerade die Nobelpreise verliehen worden.
Mir schon eingangs haben anklingen lassen und unter anderem gab es das seltene Ereignis dass eine Frau einen Nobelpreis für.
Physik das gab's jetzt noch nicht so oft und ist jetzt auch schon irgendwie wieder 60 Jahre her glaube ich.
Das ist das letzte Mal passiert ist.
Oh ja Donna streetland heißt die Frau die ist hier getroffen hat zusammen mit zwei Kollegen muss man noch dazu sagen aber das ist ja auch egal
Lasertechnik ich habe es mir ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so genau angeschaut wohin der Durchbruch so
bestand das werde ich mir dann alles wahrscheinlich in den nächsten Ausgabe von methodisch inkorrekt erklären lassen.
Das Absurde nur war das zum Zeitpunkt der Bekanntgabe.
Das ist dass sie den Nobelpreis erhalten hat es in der Wikipedia über sie noch keinen Artikel.
Und vielleicht ist das auch Nonius aber ich finde es einfach unfassbar.
Wie sehr dieser diese Mechanismen in der Wikipedia einfach falsch.
Greifen kann man sich argumentiert naja und das ist ja ist nicht ebenso klar und wir hatten schon immer sehr Einblick in diese Wissenschaft et cetera.
Ja also selbst wenn es das wäre müsste manchmal kritisieren das offensichtlich.
Auf der Administratoren Ebene nicht genug Kompetenz herrscht um quasi relevante wissenschaftliche Forschung zu bewerten.
Und hier,
Lotte rausgenommen werden die es einfach an der ständig für die da also nicht so dass noch niemand auf die Idee gekommen wäre ein Artikel zu schreiben es gab schon zwei Versuche aber ist dann halt entsprechend abgelehnt worden
was natürlich hier noch mehr dahinter steht ist
der Verdacht die man sich hier aber nicht erwehren kann dass es sehr viel auch damit zu tun hat dass es sich um eine weibliche Wissenschaftlerin handelt ja während die männlichen Kollegen halt alle schon vertreten waren,
mit vergleichbaren Leistungen wie ich nur annehmen kann.
Alles ein Problem der sich irgendwie auch diese offene Szene an der Stelle immer mal wieder Stellen Brust und ich würde mir wünschen dass wir hier weitere Durchbrüche zu verzeichnen
haben in der Zukunft bisher sehe ich davon relativ wenig das ist einfach.
Alles noch zu Exklusion istisch auf der einen Seite und ich meinen ca.
Sind falls ja noch nicht mal betrifft hätte ich nur die deutsche Wikipedia sondern auch die englischsprachige Wikipedia.
Am und bring mir einfach wünschen dass wir hier schneller Fortschritte erzielen weil geht einfach nicht meine sogar ich habe ja Wikipedia.
Seit Jahren so.
Ich glaube das ist auch nur weil du so oft gegen die Wikipedia an ankämpft aber ich habe da was da auch so früh dabei.
Ja das hat einfach auf einfach was mit meiner unmittelbaren Nähe zu diesem Kulturraum zu tun ja also hätte ich den jetzt nicht gehabt.
Keine Ahnung also nicht dass mir da jetzt irgendwie groß was drauf einbilden ist halt einfach so das ist da jetzt irgendwie abgebildet und das ist jetzt auch nicht.
Okanfella dass es so ist finde dein Penis sehr viel mehr Leute noch auftauchen nur das was eben.
Als relevant angesehen wird das ist dann doch eben sehr von der Sicht des Betrachters abhängig und der Betrachter sitzt halt auf dieser Admin administrativen.
Ebenen der Wikipedia und an der Stelle muss es einfach diverser unausgeglichener sein bzw es muss einfach auch eine Methode gefunden werden wie man eben diese Diversität und diesem breiten Blick für die Gesellschaft.
Gewinn ich persönlich habe immer so mein Beef mit mit Dingen.
Speziell in der deutschen Wikipedia kann man es jetzt auch anderer Meinung sein so aber ich habe so diverse Dinge berichtet diese aus meiner Erinnerung also aus meiner Jugend her noch
relevant waren ich mag halt auch immer wieder dass ihm auch so altes Wissen so ne mit mit dem Blickwinkel.
Mit meinem damaligen oder mit dem kulturellen Blickwinkel sieht von dem ich erlebt habe oder von dem ich denke dass er damals.
Freddy vorher sparen aber aufjedenfall existent war Anja dass ich sprechen relevante Sachen berichtet habe
Alan ein Artikel nach dem anderen ist da sozusagen beiseite gefegt worden weil das halt einfach alles nicht so interessant ist während wir auf der Wikipedia,
ausführliche Kompendien.
Über virtuelle Charaktere von Comic Spielwelten und Kartenspielen und Fernsehserien haben wo ich halt immer einfach wieder nicht verstehe
was was der Begriff Relevanz an der Stelle eigentlich leisten soll.
Ja und ich meine es ist ist bei mir im Kopf auch so eine gewisse Diskrepanz weil wenn man die Wiki
Media Community kennt also den Förderverein hinter der Wikipedia selbst und den Schwester breit und davon dann sind das durch und durch eigentlich sehr aufgeschlossene Menschen die für die sich auch genau diesen Problemen stellen.
A&R irgendwie dürfte aber
Jan gewissen disconnect geben mit der eigenen Community und dieser Geraden der Wurth ich weiß auf dem Weg habe ich drei oder vier Wikimania zu so den jährlichen Konferenz in dieser Community das wird dort alles diskutiert aber irgendwie nicht,
geschlossen also er irgendwie haben die glaube ich schon recht gar das Bild dieser Probleme aber schaffe es irgendwie nicht
dann Viktor mal rum zu finden der diese Probleme wirklich auch mal nachhaltig löst sondern das bleibt irgendwie immer in so einer Vorstufe stecken an ich meine das warm wo.
Ich will jetzt auch keinen will jetzt auch keinen absoluten Anspruch hier so darlegen nach dem Motto obwohl es manche wollten wird nichts getan.
Es wird.
Sicherlich und dafür habe ich auch gar nicht hin ein Blick viele viele viele Beispiele wo das alles viel besser geworden ist viele Projekte die angestoßen werden die das besser machen will ich auch nicht in Abrede stellen ne nur.
Diese Anstrengung müssen einfach noch weiter getrieben werden weil das zeigt sich einfach.
An diesem Fall halt jetzt mal wieder ganz exemplarisch das einfach.
Das noch nicht perfekt wird wahrscheinlich perfekt sein es kann kann nicht perfekt sein wenn man nur ein Ansatz sein aber es wäre einfach,
schön zu sehen gewesen dass man an der Stelle zumindest die Repräsentanz von
Alm was nicht der Mainstream ist ja oder sollen wir mal nicht die vorherrschende definierende kulturelle Klasse dass die auch Abbildung
findet in der Wik.
Hoffen wir's ich weiß nicht wenn uns Leute Ausrede Wikipedia kombinati zu an dass wir auch mal spannend in der Kommentaren von euch zu hören wie ihr über dieses
Problem nachdenkt ob es überhaupt das Problem mit findet oder was so eure eigenen Erfahrungen sind weil irgendwie vielleicht hilft da mehr Debatte da drüber.
Hammond.
Ich meine ich bin recht froh dass ich keinen Wikipedia-Artikel habe weil ich glaube da kommt dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass da was falsches drin steht ist größer als die Aufklärung die darüber betrieben wird aber
gerade bei wissenschaftlichen Figuren glaube ich ist es schon noch mal was anderes weil das ist ja am Ende dann auch wiederum sehr starke ego Geschichte
wenn du internationale Forschung optionen Niveau betreibst an der glaube ich ist es dann schon irgendwann mal auch Nachteil einfach nicht dieses Sichtbarkeit zurück.
Kassel ohne ohne ohne Artikel in der Wikipedia deine deine Privilegien einklagen in dieser Gesellschaft.
Ja müssen gar nicht.
Du was ich glaube wir sind am Ende der Sendung es gibt natürlich jetzt hier noch so ein.
Thema was wir vielleicht noch retten aufgreifen können aber ich glaube das Speich mir mal auf bis da mir Klarheit ist und Linus wieder da ist von daher unklare Nachrichtenlage die wir jetzt gar nicht groß auf Rollen wollen.
Ja und dieses hat uns ja eben Urlaub zu danhag gleich was zu dass er sich ein lesen kann.
Also hat meine kompakte Sendung Höhe und ja wir sehen uns ja auf jeden Fall dann auch.
Zu der Sendung während der privacy week in Wien Ende dieses Monats wo ihr ja.
Würden in Wien seit oder sein wollt auch alle gerne hinkommen möchtest mach jetzt mal hier keinen
Termin Jingle aufwärme auch schon paar mal drauf hingewiesen aber der Vollständigkeit halber sagen was noch mal das ist am 27,
Oktober um 18 Uhr im erst das Museum wieder vergessen.
Volkskundemuseum und ich glaube der Ticketverkauf hat die Woche begonnen das heißt da könnte man sich auch schon irgendwie vielleicht noch ein Earlybird checken ich weiß es nicht aber auf jeden Fall verlinken wir das.
Gut also an dieser Stelle sei mal Tschüss bis bald und das war's.